You are from Peru and you want to
study 1 university degree in Spain.
"I am the lawyer and academic advisor.
"
Diego Loaiza of safe studies.
First of all
follow us here for more free content and advice.
Now I explain how to study 1 career in Spain.
If you are from Peru,
The first question you are going to ask yourself is,
Will I get too expensive Diego?
It is very difficult and the answer is no.
Average university costs
in Peru it produces more than 15,000 soles per year,
while in Spain
the annual cost of universities
does not exceed 4,000 soles,
so pay attention and there are the requirements.
Write down,
have your education certificate
2nd and legalize it in the ugl
and after being legalized
you have to apostill it in the Ministry of
foreign relations.
Second Step
you send us the documentation in order to approve it.
We work directly
through the Ministry of Education.
Step 3
we register you for the tests taken in Lima
in June.
These tests are not complicated.
Step 4 we prescribe you in universities,
Step 5 we wait for the list of heroes
and then we enroll you in college
of your dreams.
Step 6 We apply for the study visa that allows you to
work 30 hours a week
and study,
so cheer up!
Come to Spain to study this 2 024
if you need more information.
Agenda 1 video call
free of charge with us at our channel link
and also studies in Spain with Noi this 2 024 is
study safely